este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a das
line no sé vosotros pero entre unas
cosas y otras yo me paso el día entre el
ordenador la tablet el móvil un sinfín
de dispositivos que es el trabajo que es
y leer noticias que sí oye la última
serie de esta que siempre te tiene
enganchado y al final sin darte cuenta
acabas utilizando cientos de webs donde
tienes que olvidarte y claro utilizar la
misma contraseña en todas estas webs no
es una buena idea si quieres minimizar
tu vulnerabilidad en la red pues aquí
amigos es donde entra das line para
ayudar nos das ley nos va a ayudar a
generar contraseñas seguras y cada vez
que una web te pida introducir las lo
hará por ti automáticamente también te
permite guardar tu infode pago de tus
tarjetas para tenerlo todo siempre a
mano rellenar a todo de forma rápida y
sencilla vamos es súper cómodo y
eficiente te lo digo yo quiero uso
personalmente un montón das legend
también te proporciona el monitoreo de
la tar web qué es eso pues consiste en
escanear la web en busca de datos
personales filtrados o robados alertando
te al instante en caso de que tus datos
personales
en donde no deben de tal forma que
puedas tomar medidas rápidamente super
útil como dice el dicho mejor prevenir
que curar a tu vida más sencilla y
beatas line puntocom barra visual
polític s para usar das line de forma
totalmente gratuita en tu primer
dispositivo es ilegible si quieres irte
a la versión premium usa nuestro código
visual polític s para tener un 10% de
descuento y ahora vayamos con nuestro
vídeo de hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos si las ha convertido en
todo un especialista en levantar
ciudades de la nada ciudades que en
muchos casos es verdad terminan vacías o
con tasas de ocupación muy por debajo de
las estimadas inicialmente son las
conocidas mundialmente como ciudades
fantasmas de china pero no nos vamos a
ir por ahí en este vídeo porque de eso
ya os hemos hablado en este vídeo os
vamos a hablar del nacimiento de todo un
proyecto personal del mismísimo xi
jinping un proyecto que el presidente
chino aspira a que se convierta en el
baluarte del modelo de desarrollo futuro
de todo el país un cambio de paradigma
donde el gobierno el estado el propio si
quieren jugar un papel más relevante en
el desarrollo del territorio y las
fuerzas vivas del tejido económico y
social al contrario de lo que se había
hecho hasta ahora pero amigos si los
criterios de mercado fueron los que
marcaron la ruta de las conocidas como
zonas económicas especiales o por
ejemplo son los casos tan conocidos de
shenzhen o del distrito de pudong en
shanghai este nuevo desarrollo que vamos
a ver es
completamente diferente
[Música]
nos estamos refiriendo a la nueva área
de xiong and un proyecto que ya está en
marcha y que tiene el objetivo de
construir la mega ciudad del siglo 21
una nueva ciudad que ocupará 3 condados
rurales ramon sesions jan janssen en la
provincia de hebei pero eso es tan sólo
el comienzo aunque el proyecto prevé que
en una primera fase esta ciudad ocupe
100 kilómetros cuadrados la pretensión
es que a medio plazo su dimensión supere
los dos mil para que os hagáis una idea
eso supone casi tres veces más que toda
la ciudad de nueva york 3 que situada
cerca de pekín pero en un área mucho
menos desarrollada y con serios
problemas de contaminación songun aspira
a convertirse para el 2035 en la ciudad
más tecnológica mejor conectada y más
medio ambientalmente sostenible de toda
china con un master plan que contempla
diferentes fases de desarrollo hasta el
año 2050 la inversión que el gobierno
chino se ha comprometido a realizar en
este nuevo espacio urbano es
estratosférica hablamos según las
estimaciones de morgan stanley de un
presupuesto de entre 170 y 300 mil
millones de dólares de los cuales
aproximadamente la mitad se destinarán a
dotar de infraestructuras ultramodernas
a esta nueva metrópoli
la idea es que song and complete todo un
triángulo estratégico desde el punto de
vista económico la ciudad se situará a
unos 100 kilómetros tanto de pekín como
de tianjin una importante ciudad
portuaria e industrial además que
estaría conectada en tan sólo 20 minutos
con el nuevo aeropuerto de beijing sin
la media hora del propio centro urbano
de pekín a través de un tren de alta
velocidad
[Música]
por este motivo y por el enorme reto que
supone muchos analistas y expertos han
comparado este proyecto con los casos de
extensión que impulsó el presidente de
chapín en los 80 con pudong en shanghai
que fue impulsado por bianchi min en los
90 cuando donde presentan sobre tres
seguidas máximo buch de hecho fueron
precisamente estas dos áreas económicas
especiales las que pusieron los
cimientos de la china moderna la china
abierta al mercado y al mundo sin
embargo amigos el caso de songun está
muy lejos de parecerse a cualquiera de
estas dos lo que pretende siguen ping en
este caso es justo lo contrario
demostrar que es posible una nueva china
socialista férreamente pilotada por el
partido comunista chino una ciudad donde
lo más importante no sea el crecimiento
económico orientado al mercado sino al
propio estado pero esto un momento es
que acaso es esto posible puede llegar a
tener éxito un proyecto que no pone a la
iniciativa privada en primer lugar que
se puede aprender de las
experiencia será song and un éxito o un
fracaso antes de responder a estas
preguntas vamos a echar un vistazo a la
historia de shenzhen da luz que iluminó
el amanecer del gigante asiático el
primer y exitoso experimento a gran
escala que cambió el modelo chino para
siempre atentos
[Música]
el símbolo de la revolución de herencia
o pin
queridos amigos queridas amigas de
visual político cuando hablamos de la
vertiginosa transformación de china en
la mayoría de los casos no somos
realmente conscientes de la vertiginosa
velocidad con la que se produjo ni
tampoco de cuál era el punto de partida
a finales de los años 70 el entonces
líder chino deng xiaoping fue advertido
de que los niveles de producción de
alimentos y de la industria estaban
empeorando rápidamente existía el riesgo
de que se repitiera un escenario similar
al de la gran hambruna china que mató a
millones de personas entre 1959 y 1961
por este motivo den xiaoping un líder
que ya en la era de mao pertenecía a la
reformista del gobierno decidió probar
suerte con un nuevo sistema económico
que arrancó ni más ni menos que en una
pequeña y pobre aldea de pescadores de
apenas 30 mil habitantes que estaba
pegada a hong kong
hablamos si de shenzhen allí en la
provincia de guandong el gobierno chino
estableció las primeras zonas económicas
especiales de la historia y el primer
espacio de la china continental desde la
época del kuomintang donde se permitía
la inversión y los negocios privados de
hecho en la práctica y viéndolo desde el
presente podemos decir que esa área
económica especial fue la primera piedra
en la construcción de la nueva china
para que os hagáis una idea esa pequeña
aldea de pescadores de apenas tres
kilómetros cuadrados creció y creció
hasta convertirse en todo un gigante con
12 millones de habitantes dos mil
kilómetros cuadrados de superficie y un
pib equivalente al de todo israel oa una
cuarta parte del de toda españa con un
crecimiento medio anual histórico de más
del 20 por ciento y más de 30 mil
dólares de pib per cápita desde el punto
de vista económico shenzhen se sitúa ya
al nivel de algunos de los países más
desarrollados del mundo tanto es así que
las cuatro décadas
desde que se estableció esta zona
económica especial la riqueza de
shenzhen se ha multiplicado por 10 mil
si lo habéis escuchado bien por 10.000
en apenas 40 años
no es de extrañar por tanto que éste
haya sido precisamente el motor de la
nueva china que hoy conocemos y el lugar
que ha visto nacer a empresas tan
conocidas en huawei tensen de hatay o
zte o que fuera por cierto el primer
destino que visitará el sillín ping al
estrenar su cargo el secretario general
del partido en el 2012 en cosas que
rememoran a den xiaoping cuando siguen
pin se dirige a shenzhen en su primer
viaje dentro del país y es que de hecho
esta metrópoli alberga unas 70.000
empresas tecnológicas que hacen que el 5
por ciento del pib de shenzhen se
destine a y más de ahora bien detrás de
estas cifras de locos hay algo más que
una simple zona económica especial y es
que veréis la localización elegida para
la que fue una de las primeras zonas
capitalistas de china junto a hong kong
y macao no fue en absoluto algo casual
[Música]
en 1979 hong kong y macao eran dos
territorios muchísimo más ricos y
desarrollados que el resto de la china
continental y las diferencias que
existían con shenzhen y la vecina ones
eran radicales precisamente por ello la
elección de las pequeñas ciudades de
shenzhen santo y su hai en la provincia
de guandong de la ciudad de xiamen en la
provincia de fujián y de la isla
provincia de hainán para el experimento
capitalista del gobierno chino no fue
algo casual una de las claves
perseguidas era generar simbiosis con
hong kong y macao aprovecharse de la
experiencia la actividad y los enormes
capitales humanos y financieros de estos
dos enclaves para impulsar el desarrollo
de la china continental al tiempo si el
experimento funcionaba se lograría crear
un área integrada que facilitaría de
facto en la futura absorción de macao y
hong kong que en ese momento aún no
estaban bajo soberanía china y como hoy
todos sabemos el plan salió a las mil
maravillas tanto desde el punto de vista
económico como político
ricas amigos es que el modelo de
desarrollo de shenzhen empezó a ser
replicado durante la década de los 80 y
90 por toda china hasta que llegamos al
día de hoy a la era de xi jinping xi
jinping considerado el presidente chino
con más poder desde mao ze dong y al
mismo tiempo el presidente de la china
económicamente más fuerte de la historia
tiene la tentación de probar suerte con
un modelo de área económica especial un
modelo que poco tiene que ver con el que
llevó al éxito y el desarrollo para
china queréis conocerlo pues sí ahora sí
asomémonos al nuevo sueño chino de xiong
and
[Música]
misión gan el modelo de sí para china
tal y como ya hemos dicho el nuevo área
de songun pretende romper con el modelo
de las tradicionales áreas económicas
especiales que impulsaron la china
actual
xi jinping quiere gastar lo que no está
escrito para probar suerte con un nuevo
modelo del futuro que según él mismo ha
dicho y en los próximos mil años del
socialismo con características chinas si
está mucho más convencido que den de la
necesidad de que el estado juego un
enorme y directo papel en la economía
arthur kroeber investigador sobre china
y director gerente de grave cal
dragonomics y es que aunque se oigan es
técnicamente una área económica especial
lo cierto es que en ella los criterios
de mercado no van a ser la prioridad ni
los agentes de mercado las empresas van
a tener el liderazgo no nada de eso
se trata de una zona especial pilotada y
financiada enteramente por el gobierno
central una ciudad por y para el estado
y este ciclo
[Música]
de hecho tal y como podéis ver en este
gráfico el gobierno chino tiene la
intención de que sión gan sea el mayor
proyecto de inversión pública de la
historia de china
pero la cosa no acaba aquí ni mucho
menos
[Música]
este proyecto no va a ser liderado por
empresas privadas es el estado quien
tiene la pretensión de pilotar el
proceso mediante una enorme inversión de
recursos públicos no estando orientado a
la inversión internacional y ojo porque
ni siquiera la actividad inmobiliaria
recaerá sobre la iniciativa privada
todos y cada uno de los complejos
residenciales que se construirán en sión
guns serán promovidos por el estado y la
propiedad seguirá siendo pública lo que
por cierto tiene implicaciones muy
notables fijaos
el monopolio público de la actividad
inmobiliaria hará que si un gang no
cuente con los enormes ingresos
procedentes de las transacciones de
bienes raíces que tantos miles de
millones inyectaron en el proceso de
desarrollo del área de guangzhou
shenzhen y de otras muchas áreas
económicas salpicadas por todo el país
el por cierto como en china no existe la
propiedad privada de la tierra los
granjeros que actualmente trabajan en el
área de xiong han serán directamente
despojados con una indemnización que el
estado decidirá de forma arbitraria
miles de campesinos van a enfrentarse a
serias dificultades no parecen los
mejores mimbres
una de las cosas más curiosas es que
vivir en sión gum estará estrechamente
ligado al trabajo esto puede no sonar
del todo mal pero hay un problemilla
como las viviendas son del estado al
estar ligadas al puesto de trabajo
muchos creen que perder el empleo o
cambiar a otro que esté fuera de songun
supondrá perder también el derecho a
vivir aquí más control para el partido
único
no
pero la gran pregunta es si este macro
plan se ha diseñado sin poner en primer
lugar a la iniciativa privada a ver de
qué piensa en vivir cuál pretende sin
fin que sea el motor de actividad de la
que está llamada a ser la gran ciudad de
china tal vez incluso la futura capital
de todo el país pues aunque os pueda
resultar extraño
la apuesta exclusión gana absorba en una
primera etapa las funciones no
administrativas de pekín y esto que es
bueno pues que de esta manera el
gobierno chino quiere mudar allí
universidades empresas públicas
hospitales centros de investigación y
organismos de todo tipo todo
evidentemente de propiedad estatal o con
un estrecho control del estado incluso
si quiere que la participación privada
se realice mediante consorcios que
permitan operar a las empresas privadas
pero donde el gobierno chino lleve
siempre la voz cantante es decir lo que
siempre plantea es ni más ni menos que
crear un fortín una nueva urbe que no
esté basada en el comercio ni la
competencia sino
público y además quiere que sea el
emblema de la nueva china
[Música]
los planes de desarrollo contemplan que
la población de esta nueva metrópoli
crezca durante las próximas décadas
hasta superar los 7 millones de
habitantes al tiempo que se convierte en
un modelo de sostenibilidad porque si la
idea del presidente chino es crease
jonan sea también una ciudad verde una
especie de laboratorio sobre cómo
construir los modelos urbanos en una
nueva era de empresas industrias y
transportes con bajas emisiones lo que
puede sonar raro en el país más
contaminante del mundo en cualquier caso
el primer paso ha sido cerrar todas las
fábricas y empresas de la zona que
cumplieran con los nuevos estándares
desde el 2017 el gobierno chino ha
ordenado cerrar más de 5000 empresas y
factorías en la región y el proceso
continuará hasta que la zona quede
limpia
ahora bien faltó esto muchos expertos
que han analizado a fondo el proyecto
consideran que no sólo no va a replicar
el éxito de shenzhen sino que además hay
un elevado riesgo de que la ciudad se
convierta en un rotundo fracaso lo que a
ver a mí personalmente pues no me
extraña eso te construye una urbe pasada
prácticamente de forma exclusiva en
funcionarios y dinero público que encima
está alejada de las dinámicas de
competencia e innovación del mercado a
ver qué queréis que os diga no me suena
nada pero que haga bien y se encima
tenemos en cuenta que el sector público
chino está en manos de quien está pues
aún peor dicho esto llegamos a este
punto la pregunta que todos debemos
hacernos es puede tener éxito una nueva
ciudad ajena a las exigencias del
mercado en la china del siglo 21
realmente tiene algo diferencial
rompedor que ofrecer pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
crónica de un fracaso anunciado
cuando hablamos de fracaso en términos
chinos no queremos decir ni que no se
vaya a construir la ciudad ni que no
suponga un avance para la región no
recordar que se trata de una zona rural
poco desarrollada y toda inversión en
infraestructura empresas hospitales
universidades y demás que se haga sin
duda va a mejorar la situación de
partida sin embargo siendo realistas es
muy pero que muy probable que el modelo
que si impi quiere probar en este lugar
para el futuro de china pues no funcione
[Música]
el primero de los problemas es su
localización al contrario que shenzhen
junto al financiero de hong kong y
también con salida directa al mar song
and está en el interior en una zona muy
fría en invierno cálida en verano y
donde las condiciones de vida son
relativamente hostiles y aunque las
infraestructuras que se están
construyendo ya a día de hoy son
impresionantes y prometen conectar la
nueva ciudad a pekín en media hora no
está del todo claro que eso convenza a
la gente para mudarse hasta aquí al
menos en las cifras que pekín espera
además si tenemos en cuenta las
regulaciones que van a existir para las
actividades privadas y los planes de que
sea el sector público quien tenga todo
el protagonismo songun puede terminar
convirtiéndose en una aburrida ciudad de
trabajadores públicos trasladados la
fuerza desde pequeños
y es que es un gun tiene una dura
competencia en la propia china que te
llevaría a establecer un negocio en song
and pudiéndolo hacer por ejemplo en el
delta del yangtsé
[Música]
ahora bien más allá de las dudas sobre
el éxito de esta ciudad o el rechazo que
puede generar lo que la práctica no
parece más que una involución a viejos
proyectos soviéticos de mediados del
siglo 20 diseñados para consolidar el
poder político de las felices del
partido comunista lo cierto es que la
ambición xi jinping y las enormes
cantidades de dinero comprometidas
pueden dar lugar a una especie de ciudad
museo muy particular una urbe ultra
moderna levantada de la noche a la
mañana en un lugar en el que había poco
más que campos de arroz paupérrimas
casas de campesinos no me sorprendería
si no funcionase ni siquiera a medio gas
respecto a lo que china pretende pero
será más impresionante que cualquier
otra cosa que hayamos visto en occidente
en los últimos cincuenta años se ahorró
un link experto en desarrollo
urbanístico en la comisión nacional de
desarrollo y reforma
sea como sea habrá que esperar como
mínimo hasta el 2035 para ver qué sucede
con zion gun pero amigos por el momento
los bulldozers las excavadoras las grúas
ya han entrado a los tres condados y la
construcción de las principales
infraestructuras ya están en marcha este
es el caso por ejemplo de la mega
estación de trenes de xiong aunque con
sus 475 mil metros cuadrados y un coste
de más de 1100 millones de dólares será
el eje central de comunicaciones de sión
gun está previsto que esa estación abre
sus puertas entre finales del 2020 y
comienzos del 21
[Música]
en cualquier caso lo que queda claro es
que estamos ante un nuevo experimento
con un solo objetivo consolidar el poder
de xi jinping y de los aristócratas
políticos del partido comunista de china
ojo al mismo tiempo que se ha puesto en
marcha sigan sin ping también anunciado
la creación de nuevas zonas económicas
especiales así que en sí mismo esto no
supone un cambio en la política de
desarrollo económico de china pero bueno
el experimento ahí está pero ahora turno
para ti crees que puede tener éxito la
primera gran urbe del siglo 21 diseñada
para dar la espalda al sector privado es
un proyecto aislado o crees que se
convertirá en la referencia para futuros
proyectos en china ya sabes déjanos tu
opinión aquí abajo en los comentarios si
este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle el botón de like
suscribirte a nuestro canal para no
perderte nada de lo que está por llegar
una vez más gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]